Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier, and welcome to Sheltered. Now this game Is
made by Team 17 and if you don't know
them they made the Worms game so I don't
know what this game is entirely about, it's
some sort of um, mmmanagement thing but not
like a management like er- a business
management it's where you have to make
sure that your family doesn't die
at least that's my idea. Is there a randomize
button? Boinkedy-boink-boink-boink-boink-boink-boink! Ooh! Jeffrey no
Courageous? No. Dennis? Proactive? Nah that's not me. Hands on?
Maybe. All right i'm gonna randomize ohhhh
aaaand IIII'm stoppingg... NOOOOOW!
Alright! I'm a small eater by the name of
Barbara
Hey Barbara! How you doing-oh apparently I'm
violent. Well that's good, I got all my
stats and strength and dexterity
I like it, I'm gonna go for it. Okay
here we go customize parent two- OH! THAT
WAS MY MAMMA!? Oh I thought that was me!
okay
mmmm Bippidy boppity bippidy boppity bippidy boppity
boink!
All right David, how's it going? You are
extremely well-rounded
I like that. Ok, child, hibity hobity hibity hobity hibity hobity hibity hobity, boink!
*laughing* Oh I have a fedora wearing child named Stephen. Oh God! Oh his first words were, m'lady.
Alright anyways moving on- Child two
hebity habity huh huh HAH! Mary, she's courageous,
rough-and-tumble– man, Mary is strong as
as shit.
She doesn't put up with her brothers
bullshit! All right, family name is Burnill
Pet's name is Spike and the pet is a
horse
okay i love the fact that our horse is
named Spike but i'm gonna name our
family
the Ipliers because i'm stupid like
that
and *laughing* no one likes me... You want to play the
tutorial? Yeah
sure! I'll give it a go because I have no
idea what I'm doing and I don't want
anyone out there to think that I'm
ignorant to tutorials because i'm trying my
best and I'm gonna make sure that this
family
The Iplier family *laughing* oh god, even saying that out loud is bad...
Spike! Hey Spike!
Awwwe you're adorable really bizarre but
it's adorable! Ok, so the entire family's
down stairs - oh this is cool
Ooh! I like this! Look around the shelter by
moving the cursor to the edge of the
screen with the mouse remove the camera
with the arrow keys
zoom in and out with left control. Oh
that's cool! I love this! Already, I'm in
love with this. It's a bit early to say
that- highlight an object and press the
right mouse button interact with it the
shelter is powered by a petrol generator.
Ok. Add fuel to the generator to restore power. So we need to add fuel.
GO MOMMA!!!! Baaaarbara. Barbara is the best.
I don't know which one of these I should
identify with but I'm gonna go with
Barbara because definitely not the son
Stephen
he's a little shit. Ok, commands will be
performed by the currently selected my
family member shown at the top left of
the screen
the generator must be kept ... Ohkay!
Select David for this task.
Avoid tiring, regularly fix items to prevent them from breaking. Boink! Fix.  Go! Go David,
you're so handy and well-rounded and I
like that
Barbara's a.. rough and tumble and
obviously the daughter takes after
Barbara. This icon will appear over any
items that are in need of repair.
GOT IT! Ok so he's just gonna torch that with a blowtorch apparently,
and that's gonna fix it right up.
So, alright Stephen you little shit.
Stephen Ipliers ugh that's a terrible
last name.
Oh God that's awful. Ok, Q and E to cycle through.
Stats show this character is thirsty,
red bars require attention. Remember
highlight an object and press the right
mouse button interact with it. So we
got our water barrel over here.
Medium water butt? I love that. This game is right up my alley.
With the Ipliers family
Ok so, drink water from the water butt.
Oh! There's so many jokes there but I'm just not capable enough to make 'em.
Your goal is to survive for as long as
possible. You can explore, expand,
maintain the shelter and keep the family healthy to achieve this.
Explore and gather resources by using the radio transmitter to set up an
expedition expand the shelter to build
new items from the workbench.
Your next step might be to explore, to
build, or check on your family.
How to survive is up to you.
This reminds me of 60 Seconds in a different way but only thematically
and I wanted to say
something about 60 seconds
I have tried many many many many many
MANY times to record another episode of
60 Seconds. The only thing was I didn't
want to do another episode of making
no progress so I was trying to do two
different things.
I was trying to ah... Ooo journal, I whoa
let me finish my thought first i was
trying to get the daughter to morph into
like the mutant, which helps you win or I
was just trying to win in general.
and both of those things are very
difficult to do. I didn't want to do it
on easy
I wanted to do it on normal and I
recorded and recorded I tried and tried
I've recorded hours and hours and hours
that has not worked. So I am still trying
to get that game to win.
At this point I think I might just live
stream it and just play it until I win
or until I get her to mutate, one or the
other.
I'm trying I just want to let you guys
know I haven't forgotten about 60
Seconds it's just been like... It's like
Vanish!
I keep trying it just doesn't keep
working. So anyway, so it begins
it's just us now together to whomever
read this in the future this is our head
count
Barbara, David, Stephen, Marie, and our pet
horse Spike.
It was lucky we stumbled across this
abandoned war shelter.
It seems to have seen better days maybe
with some elbow grease
we can get into good shape.
Anything is better from where we came
from
Okay good. Good news, okay so David... Let's
see does this need any repair?
No contamination. Storage crate.
We have very few stuff. KILL THE RABBIT!
EAT THE RABBIT!
It looks like we have the parts to upgrade a system.
Oh do we? Is that good? Need food, need to ration that food.
Ok oooh upgrade.
Wow! You can increase your oxygen
shelters efficiency by upgrading your
oxygen filter generator or water filter.
Cool... Shelter breaches? From what? That
sounds awesome!
Ooo! Level two work bench. Ok!
You've just assigned your shelter member
a job. Jobs appear next to the selected
members portrait, you can have a maximum
of two jobs in queue. Jobs include:
fixing, repairing, crafting, eating, drinking,
showering, sleeping.
Well I don't know any of this, but that sounds like The Sims. When you queue up stuff for your sims to do.
Okay Stephen, you little shit.
What do you need? What are you gonna do?
Ok little shit, you get on the radio and
you scan the frequencies. I don't know
what that's going to do. I don't know I'm
gonna go ahead and say I don't know what
what a lot of this stuff is gonna do.
I wish I did, but i'm just going to be
trying through this so if I'm playing
poorly. It's not out of ignorance .
Actually it's one hundred percent out of ignorance but,
it's not out of willful disregard.
It's just I don't know what I'm doing.
Okay so she needs some food.
Expand the shelter and build new items
with the workbench. Ok he's working on
on that, Barbara you
you can.
Let's be the map you can track your
expedition parties will call them back
the shelter.
Whoa! That's cool, that's awesome.  Oh man
there's so much unknown out there.
I WONDER HOW MANY SUPER MUTANTS ARE UP THERE?!?!
CUZ I'M ASSUMING... this was all part of a nuclear holocaust of some sort.
I don't have enough for that so I'm
assuming I need to set up an expedition.
Assemble your party going on expeditions
allows your shelter members to search
the wasteland for items and resources
and recruit other wasteland survivors to
your shelter.
You can have as many concurrent
expeditions as you like but the party
size is two maximum.
Um, let's make it Barbara and Marie because
she... the two of them seem to be good.
Plan a route.
Ok travel on the waypoint. So let's just
go to... I'm feeling the school
so let's go to the school and then hopefully.
Oh! We can do all these and then go
back home.
Okay got it! Got it okay! Preparation is
the key to successful expedition. You may
want to take items to trade and equip
other items and weapons for times where
your physical welfare is under
threat.
Equip gas mask to each party member, or
they might become quite ill.
Ok so, gas mask to party.
I'm just gonna take another gas mask
because I don't see. Alright, bam.
Ok! Marie ok.
equip that, equipped this. Ok now they're
good ok send party out.
Yeah they're good. Maybe. They're probably
not going to be good, they're probably
gonna die. The Iplier family is about to
have some losses here.
Yes go on. BYE! DON'T DIE PLEASE! Come back
alive and hopefully with many supplies.
Oh I get it.
Ok so, that's like a two layer door system. BYE! Oh jeez rather - rather intense don't you think.
I think.
Okay alright goodbye, have fun! We'll be here.
looks like we have an upgrade system
shelter member is tired and need sleep
tiredness prevents them from taking part
of an activity to gain experience so how
do we get them to sleep
David how do you sleep where do we sleep
is the question
oh do we sleep no that's not right, no that aint right
ok water filter integrity is good
integrity is good i guess you could - i guess you could fix that
ok so the kids still on the radio and
he's tired so how do we get him to sleep
speed up time for selection for no geez
someone's gone trying to get in touch
and icon important to answer transmissions
ok so and accept transmission
all right searching locations that the
best way to acquire items and resources
different
hello this is Marie we found a school
out in the wasteland should we check it out
search location yeah check it out
definitely that's why I sent you out
there
ok so hey wait going onto the surface
without a hazmat suit can be extremely
hazardous to your health
we're going to put one on or the effects
oh shit ahhh god damn it
david get back inside you idiot get
inside get get get
no cancel that cancel that get back
inside get a hazmat suit
then go out there are you going to get
that and then you can fix this okay so I
need to get David to stop doing that and
then
he needs to rest how do I get him to rest
how do i get him to just not do anything
how do i get him to sleep
oh we need to build the bed okay right
we found something at the school are you
interested
examine items ok you can transfer items
that you find in the wasteland to your
carried items
all right in the school Oh a mannequin
head
yeah why would i want to bring that home
oh boy ok well let's get some wood
we don't have a mannequin head you don't
have wiring you probably use a broken
radio book stress relief that be nice
magnesium sounds cool
uh the cement sure I guess we should
just bring everything but I know we're
gonna have like I i know there's going
to be things that we can have another
place okay we're done
but I don't know what's good and bad so
I'm just going to take everything for
now
ok but Stephen you need to sleep so we
need to build a craft item we need to
build a bed
they said so where the heck is a bed trip wire, bedroll... bedroll!
no that ain't it need a regular bed to
that
there we go bed alright so we need to
build the bed and we can put it right by
the radio so that we can have someone
ready and ready to go
ok so many of the shower alright Steven
I don't know how are you going to do
this but you are a mature adult you're
practically enlighten so go for it and
then David is fixing up that and
everything seems to be good so
everything seems to be coming up good
shit cmon, fuckin goddamnit
right answer the transmission
all right found small farm definitely
searching ok so finish resume
all right so he's doing that he's doing
that
think is hunky-dory were good ok alright what do ya got
ok so burnt clothes, motor that would be
good
leather is also good um looks like i
have to drop something
uhmm buh-bu-buh what do we have a lot of we
have a lot of wood so I don't think we
need the wood but this leather sounds
good and the food ration would also be
nice
I'm gonna keep that mannequin head I
know it's probably terrible but I'm
gonna keep it anyway just because it
I'm a freakin loser now i'm gonna keep
the cement okay there we go
I don't know if that's good but i'm just
going to assume ok so he's done with
that
so you just resume that he's almost done he
can take a nap he'll be good to go and
everything that we do not have a toilet
oh god that's gonna be terrible ok you
can move most of your stuff rearrange
shelter in the workbench ok so that
makes sense
alright so sleep all sweet baby boy is
going to bed then he's gonna have to
wake up and go to the thing oh that's
right they can speed up time okay
get get up wake up wake up
accept transmission right search
location right now go to bed
let's speed up time whoa
elk oh my god David
ah cancel kill the elk oh that is a
sickly looking elk by the way
geez ok maybe not ok
frick with no don't fuck it
what're ya doing ok obviously get in here but
Stephen wake up accept the god damn it
you didn't get the transmission fucking
stupid shit yes abandoned could go to
bed
we need another bed David needs to eat
something and then he needs to sleep so
we need to take over there we are but
god damn we missed the other miss the
other option
I gotta get like I i know there's a
shortcut to selecting in between the
family members but I wasn't a hundred
percent too sure about that just yet
oh there we go okay so they got there oh
they leveled up
alright cool take all but we can't fit
the water in there you kidding me we
can't fit the water
that's no good ok
yes stressed out this occurs when their
basic needs of hunger and thirst are not
not satisfied
oh boy ok but now I can actually filter
through all my people he is stressed
because he needs sleep so freaking
Stephen get the fuck up David go the fuck to
bed and then Barbara you need a shower
so let's craft a shit
good shower we don't need a good shower
we need Oh makeshift toilet that sounds
sounds important
um but I don't know if we can do that
we need a workbench level 3 before you
do that I don't know if we can upgrade
the workbench just yet we need rope in
hand why is the rope in a form of a
noose
that's kind of assuming a lot of things
here
I know it's a desperate situation but we
don't need to have that to happen in a
bundle a so it could be fun
it's all right so we need we need so
many things Marie needs a shower
Barbara needs a shower but we can't
build a shower until we get more stuff
and we can't get more stuff until we
have an expedition so we need to build
what we can first and then we'll get
things later because I think a toilet is
going to be just marginally more
important than good hygiene at this
point in time because whoa this is some
stanky people up in here but it's gonna
be even worse if we got the stink of
shit all over the place but it looks
like we have the parts to upgrade a
system
thank you marie what do we upgrade and
how do we upgrade it
oh cool ok so I don't want you to go out
on the surface but Marie of you could
upgrade the power
ah good
efficiency that sounds better but we
can't do that but we can do durability
all right go hammer on some metal plates
onto the generator and hopefully
everything is gonna go okay
like dust storm spike which might be
okay I hope spikes okay out there
little baby so this is this seems like a
problem because we need more beds
well that's what we need ok so Steven
you're sitting around so craft another
room right there
better hurry up with that you can craft
another room as well crafted another
oh god damn it I shouldn't have left the
cement
did i leave the cement I don't know
literally this meant that would've been
great
who we can make more beds oh good good
good okay you can just do that then so
let make a sleeping bag shit
there's no space we definitely better
the room Wow
steven is going to town on that earth
man I don't know
well i know its survival but making your
children dig a tunnel into the ground
seems like a bit of an extreme scenario
meanwhile David this is napping his life
away
automated shelter members will take care
of their own hunger thirst toilet
tiredness and hygiene press H or home
the switch automation off
that would be nice good oh man i don't
know why i would need to take care of
everyone individually i don't even know
how to take care of the game properly
ok David you've had enough sleep get the
Frick up
ok get get get up you need to be awake
because we need things to happen you
you need to go on an expedition goddamnit
so just David needs to go on an
expedition
uh by himself
I'm just gonna have to go by himself and
I know
actually no I'm gonna go out into the unknown
because i want to see what he can do
with what he's got
so take two bottles of water not just
one we didn't even use the last one and
one food and then off with you gonna be
gone with you
goodbye all right so then I makeshift
shower perfect okay i didn't even know
that there was a makeshift shower here
okay so he's good i did not know about
but that means that they got their needs
there they can get less stank ah god
damn it god damn i missed the goddamn
expedition
dammit yeah sassafras
oh hi David welcome back all right
he searched nothing because he did
nothing all right whatever
oh god water required holy shit it takes
a lot of water to go out on an
expedition
oh fuck well damn it i think i may have
killed everybody traumatic experience
one of your shelter members is
traumatized
oh no oh no who died
trauma what happened did someone die
no one died why are they traumatized oh god
your stink is so bad
I don't know what happened oh no spike!
oh damn it i don't know spike was dead
god damn it oh can we at least yes can
we get some water please we need more we
need to build like another water thing
craft item we need more but water
lots of salty butt water no oh whoa
hey what what a stranger has approached
your shelter you can communicate by
answering the intercom
okay uh David you want you want to
respond to this one
Laura hey if you're still alive in there
I've got some nice goods available for
trade you want to make a deal
sure you can trade your items for ok
do they have water their items they
don't have water god dammit why don't
you have water we need water a lot of it
we need a lot of water i'll trade you
all this shit all your shit for don't
know i have a mannequin head you want
that it's nice
jeez I don't have anything that I want
to trade is one radiation tablet would
be nice
okay we can do that alright sounds good
enough
yep all right thank you goodbye we're
dying remind us we are dying
so we're doing much better on water and
like things actually didn't turn out
okay it was raining we
I'm upgrading the filter our fixing you
were fixing the oxygen filter
I'm going to have Stephen set up an
expedition with just the kids because
that's the best just the kids are gonna
go out and it's gonna be great
ok they're gonna go to basically they're
going to go to all this unknown stuff
and then they're going to come back and
it's going to be great and they're going
to take these equip them they're gonna
they don't need any of the other stuff
they'll be fine now probably be fine theyre just a couple of children out they're gone
okay then David is going to be camping
out by the
meter so the he knows exactly whats going on  examine items
ok what you got coffee beans burnt
clothes limestone duct tape okay we're
going to take the limestone the duct tape,
leave everything else ok
yes food scrap pile um water we can take
that broken TV
I mean I guess sure if you can haul a TV
all the way back and then that as well
we don't need Paint at the moment so
let's just try to get all the good stuff
fuel yes i like it ok TV yeah I guess
this would take up too many spots got
plastic, i think we're good. Plyers, ah for the Iplie - ah shaddup
ok lens transistor ah shit
let's take out one of the tvs well
actually no the tvs might actually have
transistors so I think that would be
okay, but we can take out one of them for
some sand
okay, except
okay except, examine, oh oh that is
delightful
oh that is good oh that is very good we
have water so we don't need that we can
take this of the first aid kits this
wonderful the leather I like it I like
it alot
that's good i'm learning! I'm learning
how to play the game!
my god ok as soon as I think they're
done
I think they're gonna be coming back
after this and then they're going to
take care of their needs and
everything's gonna be okay okay this is
good
So Im'a Leave this episode here I don't know
if I'm going to continue playing this
game but this actually a lot of fun if I
was um better at it i'd be doing
much better but right now i'm just an
amateur but it's still I love the way
that
of the universe is out there and you
explore it out farther and farther and I
imagine things are going to get
dangerous like this obviously is kind of
close to 60 seconds but there's more
involved with building your base that's
more involved with actually going on
searching but either way I don't wanna
make a direct comparison because I know
games are games their individual things
and just because they're thematically
similar doesn't mean that they're going
to be you know it's fair to compare but
either way this is a lot of fun
I enjoyed it so thank you everybody so
much for watching and as always I will
see YOU.... in the next video
BUH-BYE!
does that mean you have a treasure know
what we still do not know that was a
thing
cool cool piece of meat and some spices
perfect exactly what I need